moments ago these men jumped out of
their helicopters into these rice fields
they are blocking the exit from the
village up ahead so far no Viet Cong tax
collectors have tried to come out this
way now these troopers of the 100 first
airborne division will move up and try
to flush the VC from hiding this
operation taking place near tweet wah is
almost a daily routine the Viet Cong
sent in squads of grain collectors and
tax collectors we send them protection
squads to capture kill or drive off the
VC if it appears there is going to be
shooting our troops try to keep the
women and kids out of the way this is
the payoff if the enemy is there he will
show now in this case we are too late he
is gone some distance away it's a
different story these captives posed as
new residents of the hamlet but their
stories made the airborne infantryman
suspicious and they are being taken in
for questioning
the circumstances of each prisoners
capture are written up on his tag this
information helps the g two officers a
great deal while they are conducting
their interrogation keeping the
prisoners blindfolded prevents them from
seeing the route taken on the way to the
American camp at the base the person is
are removed from the truck after the
blind polls are taken off their next
destination is a holding area where they
will be interrogated at length regarding
their military affiliations and
activities a concertina wire enclosure
in an open field near headquarters
effectively prevents these suspects from
getting away in addition to the wire
there is a guard now comes the
questioning the captives papers are
carefully scrutinized and then each
prisoner is asked a series of pertinent
question whether he answers the
questions or not the prisoner is fed and
he finds American food is good
it is 20 july at play KU units of the
25th Infantry Division prepare for
another combat mission during operation
Paul Revere in the central highlands of
Vietnam a joint operation Paul Revere
began on 10 May under the command of
Brigadier General Glenn d walker of the
25th division and involve troops of the
Republic of Korea tiger division as well
as the u.s. 25th division now after
inflicting heavy casualties on the
regular North Vietnamese forces at play
me to the southwest the men of the 25th
prepare to fly north and secure a new LZ
in Viet Cong controlled country finally
all is in readiness and the task force
takes off from play coup for the 96
kilometers light through their objective
in the highlands
as the helicopters fly over contemn
province the countryside below seems
deserted here and there the jungle parks
to reveal grassy meadows and low growth
but there is no sign of life once they
pass over some old bunkers built by
American forces during an earlier Search
and Destroy operation the emplacements
and the dirt road now abandoned as the
war moves on
then they are at the objective another
of the grassy islands in the midst of
jungle covered mountain sides there is
no enemy fire and security troops begin
scouring the area in a short while the
first howitzer is brought in by Chinook
helicopter and placed where the crew can
get at it unloading of ammunition and
other supplies is quickly accomplished
another tube artillery piece arrives
soon troops of the task force will sweep
the surrounding area and a 90 millimeter
mortar is used to hit vantage points
overlooking the valley corridor the
landing zone is now secure in the
build-up of weapons and supplies is
rapid as this phase of operation Paul
Revere proceeds on schedule
these North Vietnamese prisoners of war
were captured by troops of the US 1st
air cavalry division during Operation
Paul Revere to which commenced on one
August when the 1st Air Cav was added to
operation Paul Revere now on 17 August
at flick ooh premiere key and other
dignitaries of the South Vietnamese
government visit the joint us and Korean
forces engaged in the operation a great
variety of captured enemy weapons is
displayed on this occasion
from your key speaks to one of the enemy
prisoners then in the ceremonies which
follow Major General John Norton
commanding general of the 1st Air Cav
and Brigadier General Glenn d walker
commanding general 3rd Brigade 25th
infantry division received Vietnamese
national awards there are awards too for
many of the participants in the joint
operation including men from each of the
military units both American and Korean
continuing the operation on 19 August
troopers of the 1st Air Cav secure
another landing zone codename cat and
are surprised when a group of North
Vietnamese surrender with their weapons
the prisoners are reported to have
surrendered because of our psychological
warfare leaflets soon after the landing
zone has been secured the troops are
resupplied by aerial drop from a c-130
elsewhere on the 19th of August a
peculiar accident Flags another unit of
Paul Revere troops
several kilometers north of LZ cat at a
forward artillery position major-general
norton hears that the rotors of a
chinook helicopter blue flames from a
campfire onto a stockpile of 105
millimeter howitzer ammunition some of
the rounds exploded while others were
scattered over a wide area three men
were injured in the blast and
considerable damage done the problem now
is the partially damaged ammunition the
dangerous items of munitions must be
removed one of the battery officers
carefully picks up a damaged round and
hands it to one of the men the soldier
cradles the round in his arms for
greater stability then in a hair-raising
trip picks his way across bumpy terrain
for several hundred meters until he
reaches the site selected for demolition
of the faulty round
at the dumping grounds he is relieved of
his burden by a lieutenant who has
prepared a place for the shell
throughout the area men continue to pick
up and transport the dangerous rounds to
the disposal pit a nerve-racking
experience even for the comest of men
mission accomplished in this unexpected
incident during Operation Paul Revere to
80 kilometers east of Saigon members of
the 170 third Airborne Brigade searched
the village of za one lock for suspected
Vietcong guerillas part of operation
Toledo the search is taking place on 31
August residents of the village which is
just outside the 170 thirds forward
command post at za gra are individually
check this man is being held as a
suspected member of the Vietcong
paramilitary 2 weapons were found hidden
in his home completing their search
without further incident the airborne
troopers pull out and return to the
armored personnel carriers which have
been providing security on the perimeter
of the village as in every operation
medical aid is provided for the
population of the village the mid-cap
and dent cap programs conducted by
american military forces in Vietnam are
in sharp contrast to the Vietcong
terrorist tactics which are designed to
deprive villagers of whatever little
they may have aside from gifts of food
there is nothing which is more
appreciated by these people than medical
assistance
the children are always brought forward
first while the adults patiently await
their turn for treatment meanwhile at
the 170 thirds forward command post at
za gra pehle born assault troops fly in
for regrouping and a night's rest before
being sent on a new mission during
operation Toledo the operation which
began on 10 august has taken troops of
the 170 third into the provinces of Fort
we long con and Binh Thuy in the first
20 days of the operation Search and
Destroy missions have been carried out
from the area around buntao to within a
few kilometers of Saigon but little
contact has been made with the enemy
now on the first of September the sky
troopers are once again being prepared
for action the men from the first wave
move off the landing zone with the
landing zone clear the second wave of
airborne infantry begins arriving this
phase of operation Toledo is to be
carried out in battalion strength and
the incoming air traffic has to be
controlled with precision to avoid
accidents on or above the landing zone
as each helicopter touches down the
soldier passengers immediately scramble
off so the chopper can take off and make
room for more on coming aircraft
then all up and down the airstrip the
men move off the landing zone and go to
join the troops along the perimeter at
the staging area alongside the field men
of the various units are regrouped and
form up for the brief march to Vivek
area where the battalion will spend the
night soon the airborne assault troops
are headed for a good night's rest
tomorrow they will descend upon another
sector of the second core area as
operation Toledo continues
on August 19 ambassador Henry Cabot
Lodge arrives by helicopter at the
village of war loi that is about 64
kilometers west of Saigon this village
ADC stopping point was sealed off the
day before in a joint operation by
elements of the 1st infantry division
and the Vietnamese Army as explained to
ambassador Lodge the village is now
undergoing a pacification program the
program starts with sealing off by
airborne troops and then all males from
18 to 45 are separated for questioning
by the Vietnamese National Police at the
same time the other villagers are taken
to a secure area where a hamlet festival
has been organized by the American
troops lieutenant colonel james wallace
of the 1st Infantry Division who is in
command of the operation briefs the
ambassador our part in this operation
divide the court around the city
yesterday afternoon in order to prevent
any VC suspect escaping from the city
and also to provide the security or the
conducts to have a festival today among
those attending the briefing with
Ambassador Lodge our general seaman
commanding general second field forces
and general one of the army of Vietnam I
owned at the time attached to it what
they
true from the first tie and forth
Catherine the hamlet festivals known as
lung song play a dual role in the
pacification program first they keep the
villagers in a separate area while the
rest of the village is being searched
for enemy troops and supplies second
they create an atmosphere of mutual
trust and goodwill by providing food
medical aid and entertainment put it in
my hands I said go like this again I got
one of our boss sports players right
this is a google holy smokers and you
got one little square of you after the
briefing the Ambassador personally
examines the lumps on in action mess
tents prepare food for both the
occupying troops and the villagers
following his visit to war loi
ambassador lodge flies on to another
Hamlet where pacification was completed
in june
bunn robe a secured by the 100 first
airborne during Operation John Paul
Jones in late July is the scene of an
effort to develop this natural Harbor
into an important supply point for units
in the tweet wha area while the 100
first secures the area from vantage
points above the bay a task force
composed of several engineer units works
as quickly as possible to complete
Harbor facilities which will help
relieve demands on cam ranh bay and the
truong to the south the 39th engineer
battalion has the responsibility for
building the ramp for the main pier and
to LST ramps of the shoreline as well as
the staging area on the beach because
the hot humid climate affects the
setting of concrete the ramps are poured
and smooth in the late afternoon and
evening the pier itself is being built
by a port construction company it is a
tide flexible pier made a cuticle
pontoon section
on another part of the beach men of the
diving section connect units of a
flexible pipeline which will enable oil
tankers to unload without docking at the
pier from a barge in the bay the
completed pipeline is pulled out by
winch to where it will be sunk and
secured on the bay floor a marker buoy
keeps the head of the oil pipe afloat
next step is the setting of the mooring
buoy to which the tankers can be secured
while unloading a huge anchor which in
turn is attached to a concrete block
weighing several tons is positioned and
lowered into the water then everyone
stands clear as the ropes holding the
heavy chain are cut when the system is
operational petroleum will pass from the
ship to the beach by pipeline up along a
railroad cut and through the mountains
by way of Babineau railroad tunnel
eventually reaching that's we thought
Hank farm highway 1 lies only a few
kilometers inland from the bay but
construction of a road to meet it is
perhaps the most challenging task for
the engineers often charges are set to
blast away outcroppings barring the way
then the bulldozers get back to work
carving a steep path out of the rugged a
stockman
progress is rapid and the route begins
to take shape promising to open bong
robe a as an important new supply point
in Vietnam
on the lung Tao River 40 kilometers
southeast of Saigon salvage operations
get under way for the American cargo
freighter baton rouge victory which ran
aground and sank to its main decks after
striking a bc mine on 24 august the
twisting long towel river is the favored
shipping route to the port of saigon and
on a number of occasions this year Viet
Cong guerrillas have attacked passing
cargo vessels in an attempt to block the
vital supply channel Vietnamese
officials ordered the area close to
shipping until salvage crews complete
raising and removal of the 8500 ton
freighter to vung tau for repairs
the rehabilitation center for crippled
children in Santo Domingo operates with
funds contributed in part by soldiers of
the inter-american peace force the only
center of its kind in the country the
clinic currently treats over 2200 cases
at present the center consists of one
crowded room containing examination
booths officers and a gym for special
therapy a small overworked staff headed
by dr. alfredo Contreras treats the
young patients most of whom are victims
of polio cerebral palsy or deformities
of the legs in the brace shop mr. Olaf
Hansen of Denmark a United Nations
employee is teaching seven Dominicans
who are themselves physically
handicapped the design and construction
of braces shoes and other appliances
fully sixty percent of the center's new
cases are leg deformity this is due to
poor nutrition and or the lack of
prenatal care until recent times the
physically handicapped Dominican child
was considered a loss and was given no
education to counteract this the centre
is beginning a school to be run by a
government paid teacher
Brigadier General Robert R Linville
commanding general US forces Dominican
Republic arrives at santo domingo's
kiskeya stadium to attend the baseball
tournament playoffs of six US forces
sponsored teams of Dominican use during
the week end of August 26-28 the junior
league tournament gets underway with US
forces and Dominican national police
officers in attendance along with a
goodly turnout of team supporters
general Linville shares the spotlight
with police chief general Alvarez in
throwing out the traditional first ball
the teams for Dominican boys 18 to 20
years old are supported and coached by
various US Army units the essential
equipment and some uniforms have been
supplied by these units
the teams playing in the seven game
tourney come from villages and suburbs
of Santo Domingo us major league
professional rules are in effect in all
game following the sunday afternoon
championship game trophies supplied by
the US Army are presented to the winning
arroyo hondo team by Colonel Darrow G
would commanding officer of the
sixteenth general support group and
Colonel FP field chief of staff the most
valuable player award goes to me well
Montano a first baseman for the
championship team looks like a good time
was had by all
the School of the Americas located at
Fort Gillick in the Canal Zone boasts
one of the most unique mess halls in the
army more than 200 Latin American
students hailing from 18 different
nations study technical skills and
leadership techniques at the school and
though the normal diet of a Bolivian
from the Andes and the Venezuelan from
the coastal jungles is far different
they all find familiar and tasty food
awaiting them at Chow time the man
responsible for this feat of catering is
mess steward sergeant Ramon Santana
although the mess is taken from the army
master menu sergeant Santana with 18
years of experience behind him manages
to add a Latin American flavor to a
variety of his dishes operating with the
staff of four cooks and ten KPS sergeant
Santana often finds himself preparing
veal cutlets in a vinegar and onion
sauce or substituting rice for potatoes
salads and tropical foods are served as
much as possible preparing meals for
such a mixed group of nationals is a
difficult assignment but the sergeant
and his staff are more than equal to the
task his mess has won the four kulick
command award for four months running
in July a Brazilian Air Force plane
arrives in Rio de Janeiro with officers
who are members of the inter-american
peace force stationed in the Dominican
Republic these officers will spend their
leave in Brazil while Brazilian officers
may fly on US Air Force planes to visit
Puerto Rico leaving the airport the
party has a short drive through a city
that is almost 500 years old although
there's is not an official visit they
will make some courtesy calls before
going on with our sightseeing trip they
meet general de almeida staff president
of the inter-american peace force in
another office Lieutenant General von
delay Brazilian chief of staff welcomes
army lieutenant Fred fascist jr. and
Captain Mike Maloney to Rio and
congratulate them on being able to take
part in the exchange program during
their stay the allied officers also
visit the city of são Paulo in this
industrial center the party tours
several modern factories this automobile
production and assembly line is one of
the newest and most efficient in the
world nestles products and thus and bra
company are some more examples of a
nation rapidly expanding its production
facilities two of the pleasures of a
stay in Rio or a late breakfast followed
by a swim at the famous Copacabana beach
even though in July it is winter in
Brazil captain Maloney and Lieutenant
bashas are willing to brave the elements
quite possibly the water seems warmer
when shared with their charming
companions two young ladies who are also
vacationing in Rio their lead is soon
over and the officers must return to
their duties in the Dominican Republic
similar exchange trips took place once a
month from april to September 1966
during this period more than 40 officers
of the inter-american peace force
artists
faded in the program
you